bertrand le grand merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france alors docteur
port du masque distanciation social ces
mesures sont rentrés dans le quotidien
des français
et pourtant nous sommes en pleine
seconde vague et d'autres suivront a
prévenu le conseil scientifique comment
est ce que vous le comprenez on comprend
en regardant les chiffres que cette
deuxième vague est manifestement
beaucoup plus haute que la première il
suffit de regarder la pente de cette
deuxième vague on voit bien qu'on est au
tout début au pied de cette deuxième
vague et c'est pas foncièrement étonnant
puisque depuis le mois de septembre nous
les médecins de ville alertons sur le
fait qu'il ya un énorme demande de soins
en matière de risques co lead et que
donc bien évidemment ce soin là va
déferler maintenant sur l'hôpital
l'hôpital est déjà débordé il lui reste
six semaines d'augmentation d'un de
l'intensité des hospitalisations à subir
donc effectivement mes collègues
hospitaliers on risque de souffrir
énormément et vous aussi donc dans votre
cabinet vous voyez de plus en plus de
malades qui ont les symptômes finalement
dû coronavirus alors en fait moi je suis
arrivé au maximum de ce que je pouvais
faire donc je ne vois plus
l'augmentation je ne vois plus que la
stabilité de mes capacités soigner mes
patients je suis arrivé au maximum et
tout ce qui est au dessus du maximum
mais malheureusement pas pris en charge
alors le conseil scientifique plutôt
pessimiste sur l'évolution de la crise
sanitaire c'est votre cas également
wheeler pessimiste c'est évident qu'on
n'est pas dans la partie de la première
vague où on pouvait espérer maîtriser le
ce qui nous arrive est dessus et
clairement là on a bien tous compris que
la deuxième vague n'est absolument pas
freinée par les mesures qui ont été
prises auparavant voire même elles ont
été amplifiées par le passage de la 14è
n'a la septaine tiens je vous le
rappelle relâcher des personnes
contagieuses dans le milieu
professionnel et maintenance ou de cette
vague là va devoir
arrivé avec les six semaines de retard à
la prise de décision et je vous rappelle
qu'on est toujours pas changé
cette 14 ème phase retour à la 14è n'est
toujours pas actée donc on a énormément
de retard par rapport aux virus et il va
falloir encore subir pendant six
semaines
alors on a vu ce matin notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux des vidéos
d'embouteillage en région parisienne
mais pas seulement on en a vu aussi à
rennes la vie professionnelle finalement
continue la vie scolaire aussi ce
confinement partiel il reste suffisant
néanmoins pour surmonter cette seconde
vague non on voit bien que le déni et
complet je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous il suffit de ressortir dans la
dans la rue pour se rendre compte que
effectivement une ce confinement n'est
pas un confinement au sens propre du
terme et donc du coup son effet sera
forcément insuffisant mais je pense que
les français ne sont pas prêts à
entendre que la deuxième vague est bien
présente et qu'elle sera plus forte et
que nous d'eux allons devoir faire des
stries en réanimation c'est juste une
évidence c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
donc pourquoi sa mère et de sa femme et
ça ça se voit ça par hasard ça va
forcément ça va s'arrêter mais je
français sont après de l'entendre et
c'est ça veut dire pour où il faudrait
finalement une bonne fois pour toutes
re avoir un nouveau confinement total
ça serait ça la solution aujourd'hui la
tristesse c'est que malheureusement le
confinement c'est le constat de l'échec
aujourd'hui on en est au point où la
france et les français ne veulent pas
entendre ce constat de l'échec
on est dans un déni telle que même les
chèques qui est sous nos yeux ne paraît
même pas possible bien entendu avant le
confinement il aurait fallu bien
évidemment passer de la septaine à la
14ème bien évidemment il fallait
renforcer les mesures de protection en
milieu scolaire il ya tout un tas de
mesures que l'on a pris
maintenant si cette semaine qui ont été
très mauvaise et qu'il fallait corriger
avant d'arriver au confinement mais le
retard mis en place par le gouvernement
pour corriger ses erreurs et tels que on
est contraint de confier alors que ça on
en a même pu les moyens ni les capacités
ni les moyens politiques ni les moyens
économiques est bien évident alors il ya
eu là la rentrée scolaire ce matin est
ce qu'on veut crainte des clusters dans
les écoles des foyers de contamination
parce qu'il ya encore cette
interrogation est ce que les élèves sont
contagieux ou pas il ya toujours des
débats qui ont entend ici ou là quel est
votre regard sur 700 rend très longtemps
j'ai cru que les enfants n'étaient pas
vecteur de la maladie parce que dans mon
cabinet j'ai envoyé très peu qui était
en amont de la contamination des adultes
et donc de sur ce fait là à la première
vague
j'étais intimement persuadé que les
enfants étaient très peu contagieux
force est de constater aujourd'hui que
la réouverture des écoles à la manière
dont cet effet en septembre avec un déni
total puisque je vous rappelle qu'on a
refusé d'admettre que des clusters
étaient présents dans les écoles pour ne
pas les fermer
et donc ce déni malheureusement nous
prouve que les enfants sont bel et bien
contaminants en vis-à-vis de leurs
professeurs et inversement
et que donc dès 6 ans très clairement
les enfants son continent c'est une
évidence aujourd'hui on peut pas on peut
pas nier cette évidence alors ses élèves
dès le cp a d'ailleurs qui porte le
masque certains disent qu'il serait
nécessaire de continuer de le porter à
la maison est ce que ça a un sens à la
maison malheureusement alors je suis
bien placé pour vous le dire puisque
moi-même je suis testé positif aux que
jd et que donc je ne fais plus
travailler dans mon cabinet mais je
travaille par tva consultation bien
évidemment que le sort d'une famille est
le même et il est partagé pour tous il
est complètement ridicule de penser qu'
on ne compte elle n'aura pas ses proches
je sais bien que la sécurité sociale m'a
dit que si je faisais très attention je
ne comptais me n'aurai pas mes proches
mais en réalité c'est totalement faux
nous savons tous très bien que quelqu'un
qui tombe malade contaminera ses proches
c'est des enfants il ya moins de risques
si c'est des personnes âgées bien
évidemment que le risque est majeur
alors vous qui est du coup en
télétravail
aujourd'hui est ce que finalement ça
fonctionne bien ces consultations à
distance
est ce que ça peut permettre finalement
de de résoudre les files d'attentes chez
chez le médecin ou à l'hôpital d'avoir
recours au télétravail pour les médecins
ou alors il manque quelque chose
donc pour faire le même nombre d'actes
me faut à peu près 30% à 40% de temps en
plus un c'est beaucoup plus compliqué et
avec un risque qui est plus important
puisque je n'examine pas mes patients
donc non c'est vraiment un pis-aller
on s'en était parfaitement du compte
pendant la première vague et dès qu'on
pourra abandonner la téléconsultation je
serai ravi de pouvoir l'abandonner la
qualité de service fait à mes patients
et est absolument déplorable par rapport
à un examen clinique correctement mené
donc je n'ai qu'une seule hâte c'est de
pouvoir rpt que retouché mes patients et
les réexaminer
mais pour l'instant c'est
malheureusement pas dans le
bénéfice-risque push
merci beaucoup au docteur bertrand
legrand bon rétablissement à vous en
tout cas je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin généraliste